last week it was reported that Suicide
Squad killed the Justice League had been
delayed alongside their news were fans
hoping to develop a rock steady would
ditch the game's live service elements
if you were one such fan I'd advise
against getting your hopes up reporting
on Twitter reporter Jason schreier
provided new insight on his previous
report about the game's supposed delay
he said Rocksteady hasn't come forward
to officially announce the delay
possibly because no new date has been
chosen Strayer said staff were informed
weeks ago that killed the Justice League
was shifting to later in 2023 but it
remains possible that the game could
move to 2024 amid all the unknowns
schreier said there is one thing that
appears to be clear and that's how the
core game isn't changing this seemingly
pertains to how kill the Justice League
is an online live service game that
requires a constant internet connection
even for its single player mode the game
was featured during a February state of
play broadcast for PlayStation with an
extended gameplay a demo some people
didn't like the live surface approach
but as the original delay report said
Rocksteady is apparently not going to
change its plans the reported delay is
supposedly being undertaken to give the
developer more time to polish the game
and get it ready for launch another game
that's getting ready for launch is
Starfield which is set to hit an Xbox or
PC near You in September one big step a
game takes when preparing to be sold to
the masses is getting a rating and this
week the ambitious space-faring sci-fi
RPG received a rating in Australia and
it's something of a surprise the
Australian classification board has
given Starfield a rating of r18 plus
which means the game contains content
considered high in Impact for players
the rating page states that starfield's
rating mainly stems from its depiction
of unspecified drug use the r18 plus
rating is noteworthy considering
bethesda's previous games like Skyrim
and Fallout 76 received the lower rating
of ma15 Plus for Starfield as you can
see in the classification breakdown on
screen other content vectors showed that
Starfield received a moderate impact
distinction for its themes a strong
impact label for violence and another
moderate impact for language for nudity
Starfield received a very mild impact
rating and a nun for sex the ratings
description doesn't provide any
specifics though unfortunately Starfield
and Suicide Squad are both games that
can't be played right now Diablo 4
however is playable as it is currently
hosting its first of two beta periods
this weekend's Early Access beta runs
from today March 17th to March 19th and
is an invite-only beta meant for those
who pre-ordered the game or ordered a
qualifying chicken sandwich at KFC the
second weekend March 24th to March 26th
will be open to anyone who has a
supported platform and will likely see
longer cues as even more players try it
out the beta isn't just the test of the
game either as you can get some extra
goodies for the final game if you reach
a certain level for both sets of dates
the beta will kick off at 9 00 a.m
Pacific noon Eastern and run until the
ending date at noon Pacific 3 pm Eastern
it's worth noting that progress from the
early beta will carry over to the open
weekend but not to the full game when it
launches later this year so don't worry
about getting too attached to your
character I'll be playing the beta later
today and throughout the weekend and I'm
pretty new to the Diablo Series so drop
some tips for me in the comments below
foreign